[Music]
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for us to watch
I've never seen an Apple TV show have
you I've seen a little Ted last so
whatever SC we are watching Monarch
because we are entering the monster
first I'm so excited ladies and
gentlemen breathe fire into that like
button also I'm putting John and Andrew
on watching Shin Godzilla so excited I
haven't seen it's a good movie so I hope
that you guys enjoy hopefully we get
that by next week subscribe click the
notification Bell cuz we are going to be
of course covering the rest of this
series thank you to prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights as always
full length re action watch Longs resync
up with your own copy of Monarch that is
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page cover several
things exclusive there have some watch
Longs included but with this being the
first episode it is made public for
everyone so there's a link in the
description box if you want to do the
watchalong experience to see what that's
all about any who let's get into action
people see how good this show actually
[Music]
is
cool oh is it starting off on like Kong
Skull Island looks like it oh yeah this
is like POV from that
sequence whoa someone in the helicopter
at a
[Music]
camera how this feels
like I don't know if this will good to
you I hope so actually I don't because
it'll probably mean I'm dead which you
may not feel too busted up about I do I
can't go back in time and fix all the
mistakes I made but maybe I could leave
something for the future it's okay
Connor is all worth
it
oh is always worth
it w a full on scene yeah this
definitely feels like some out of a king
pong Kong
movie Bill Rand lost a bunch of weight
to you just his past few sequences in
fact damn look at the budget on this
thing
cool
ah gu doing what he loved
oh gnarly or
Not crab battle crab battle crab
battle wow just in the right place at
the right time
[Music]
huh
whoa
damn
pretty cool POV this really does feel
incredibly
cinematic oh no manag to restore the
camera hey hey fil in the background oh
that's right good
catch skull
crawler oh maybe we'll get Matthew
broadrick to appear dude it would be the
ultimate crossover Justice for broadrick
that's a lot of
fish I got the has her technology to
actually that kind of
[Music]
millimeter you know it really it would
depend on how corroded the film is I
guess there's probably some but past the
point you're probably you know
screwed this is a cool opening
sequence like C is a real mystery
element and the mirrored RAR Shack ink
plot likee images suggest that this is
going to test our unique perspectives in
the lives of our characters and also the
dueling timelines yeah
definitely well also too as we saw in
God's love versus Kong there is that
alternate world yes Hollow Earth baby I
mean there's got to be some Hollow Earth
stuff in here
Matt for Action huh
interesting the guy did want Vision no
no no Matt fraction wrote the Hawkeye
run didn't he oh yes Matt shackman Matt
shackman though whoa they're
both really got to learn some Japanese I
wanted to so badly in eighth grade we
have to wait don't do it
welcome to topical yes like like a
normal flight in in these days it's all
about giving us the illusion of
safety like spraying us for parasites
would help prevent another monster
attack
yes one of you guys drug it
in oh that's
haunting it's feel like a sci-fi mystery
yeah oh snap cool oh was that from the
2014 Godzilla movie sure looked like it
yeah I was trying to check my memory in
terms of where the years align but yeah
and it's cool because it hearkens back
to like the very fleeting glimpses we
would get in that movie what is the
purpose of your visit to Japan my father
died recently and I'm settling his
Affairs so business I guess family
business oh is she the daughter of is
she uh uh uh sarawa daughter Ken watab
Ken Kenny Kenny W or are we being racist
we could be being racist but I hope not
well no it would only be racist if we
thought she was
kenwan but everywh going she's
asan the government is spending lots of
money missiles drones are you in the
trade mosa prep big business now oh
people always find a way to profit off
someone else's tragedy more profit than
tragedy some Frisco was a hoax they did
it with CGI yes it's a deep fake that's
quite a revelation there more I have a
podcast you're Brian Tyree Henry it's
interesting seeing like the civilian
real world response to this that's some
of my favorite world building is yeah
just like the big you know giant monster
sticker on the ground or like the
missiles they set up hi Mom you said you
call when you landed and I just landed
yeah 2 hours ago you think you'll just
be sitting here waiting for someone to
bring him home so we should have gone
with your plan sit here staring at the
walls never knowing what this means
interesting
[Music]
cut subtle for boting
note that is not Kim Watson h no I guess
I was wrong I'll take the blame I'm a
racist who are you who
[Music]
apartment why do you have these
pictures how did you get in here I have
the keys what the hell's happening I'm
not I found them in my father's desk
along with the leas for this apartment
in his name I don't know who your father
is but this is our apartment it's Brian
Cranston this is my father oh he started
another family Oh
weird
that guy's like damn I have a hot sister
I feel so
conflicted you couldn't have got us a
vehicle that was at least somewhat
vehicular my God why is kids you know
bil it's the pedal on the lap hey what's
the rule on commentary from the back
seats you sure this is the right Road
let me
check let me just read the radiation
real quick hell it never plan on having
kids anyway there was a time when you at
least entertaining the idea there was a
time where that idea was very
entertaining are they former lovers
don't make things awkward tell us it's
cuz you never met the right
woman uhoh being able to keep Monarch
together that's no small
feet what we've done we've done together
the two of us yeah I feel like there was
a sexual tension between them the way
they're framing this it seems like
there's definitely something between the
two of them at least her and Wyatt
Russell the Army gave me one job swab
was keeping you Eggheads alive just
follow my lead for a change please
where's
Godzilla not destroyed anything yet
except some people's PTSD what's all
this like mood and atmosphere and
character building buildup and
[Music]
themes locations they shot this on are
beautiful kind of wish it was a volume
although to be fair I think the first
scene was a bit of a
volume put down your weapon calm down
whoa can't keep your mask
on they guilty about
that they've already been eating
[Music]
it
this Godzilla will rage against
[Music]
misinformation to the hollow hell is her
father Kim Watson
a assum they're all related to
Ken or or is it the other woman's mother
I don't
know
Chernobyl I haven't even seen Chernobyl
but anything with this
aesthetic and radiation gets the
Chernobyl treatment it's a required
reference point the problem is there is
no radiation that's impossible standing
at Ground Zero oh my God why Russell
just had a
kid radiation is definitely not real yep
yep clear sign prove it where's your
proof a bunch of pictures I've got
pictures uh-oh they're also living here
yes they probably have lots of
documentation this is our
backyard he built that Playhouse for me
when I was five my man's was Polly can
you tell us anything we have been
waiting
looking but here she's G this is really
hard the toll that it would take on a
revelation like this I'm sorry I Jin
here um let's just forget this happened
are you kidding
me help me understand breaking my heart
right now I wish I could
here my hot
sister I'm so
conflicted my father's double life or my
hot
sister half sister so it's okay yeah
half of it is is yeah it's been absorbed
by
something yeah or eaten by whom what
it's not like we haven't seen it before
these things think the a Anda bombs
stand for appetizer come on time for
some science
last charges set these are supposed
to be set at 50 m apart the larger ones
the 3.8 Mega well that's what we brought
NOP fire in the hole what job
Workaholics
guy is that wait ORS what Chambers deep
in the
Bedrock there's something down there
those are off the charts off the chain
yes so mature by the Revelation they're
like the couple in Prometheus and he's
like one of the other
guys what have you
awakened
this is it yes gamra that sudden shift
from celebration to Terror oh Kate what
did you find out whose apartment is it
it's his mom are you
there Mom
Mom oh no oh no
emergency I can't believe Kim Watson AE
fed all these
people he's prolific guy all right early
warning system warning for
what D how they F her yeah really they
must have followed her right out the
door oh get in the Godzilla evacuation
area it's an interesting time to set it
in because by this time in this story
the timeline they've only seen Godzilla
and the um and the M MOS yeah she wants
to know if he was with you when it
happened was he with you oh no what
difference does that that make no you
don't think it would have made a
difference if he'd been here with us
instead keeps treating her like
knew he wasn't with me in the Multiverse
he was
there how D you fun oh my God are you
okay oh my God every not follow me take
a charge Follow Me Oh interesting CGI
effect there
waa face to
face damn you're such a good
person oh that is
scary oh my God oh my goodness
that
yeah I'll scar you solid edit there way
to map out those
transitions let me go let me someone
suffering the PTSD like a Godzilla
Survivor yeah which is I mean of course
yeah there's got to be so many of them
and it compliments the tone especially
of that 2014 movie pretty well which I
feel like is very very underrated well
you know they didn't do the one thing
Godzilla always does which is only show
Godzilla and nothing
else a she's comforting her the mom is
great you think that's her mom I think
that could be no wait her mom's that
lady in America maybe it's her grandma I
don't know maybe this is is that woman
is is the other is the mom of the other
family maybe it's just an Asian lady
maybe
it's they're all just
Asian
some new form of M they look
embryonic like larvae new form of m mom
can't be far away right we need to get a
sample the genetic material mhm jump in
there boy so you want to go down there
well yeah I mean they appear to be
dormant wa what a crazy sideways angle
so is this what lates to the events of
the San Francisco outbreak your Bo can
pull me up if I get in trouble
okay we are not just letting you go down
there
no you're not letting me uh-oh uh-oh how
much time you need down there to collect
enough genetic material 5 minutes oh no
if I'm not back in 5 minutes just wait
[Laughter]
longer all
clear has been can I think this mom's
going to die yeah I'm afraid them
brother and sister are going to learn to
get long while he deals with his Lust
For
Her becomes it becomes like Michael fast
Bender in shame for that Supply did you
get the answers and what these unlock
and all you found was dad was apparently
a lying he's got so many other
apartments you think our father was so
bad I want to show you something I want
to show you his storage locker full of
McGuffin look around am I looking for
anything in particular just drink it in
he just wasn't you say he was maybe you
just didn't know
him maybe we're both kind of right what
are you do anyway let me guess Computer
Engineering something that would make
dear old dad proud I'm a gamer sounds
like he had a much better relationship
with the hey
yep I didn't know it was
there that's why you got to look behind
the opening credits like you really get
the sense that the two of them were
raised completely different what's your
birthday stop doing that show me
something I didn't know about him cuz
the only thing in this room that isn't
old news to me is this July 7 77 what
about your mom you wouldn't be that
obvious afraid of what we'll find August
17th your birthday seriously stop I'll
never get it
open
hey how did you do that it's her
birthday yeah your birth month my day
your mother's month my mom's day but he
loved you all all of you stop being mad
at him this Locker combination is the
[Laughter]
[Music]
proof he was the guy on the boat or that
could have just been a random Japanese
[Laughter]
[Music]
Fisher my
Randa
look how much monor cares about their
people yeah I need to know what this is
it's some kind of old data storage it's
private I'll make you a deal you help me
and I'll get out of your life forever
what about he helps you and then come on
me well where do we know this woman from
have you seen a format like this before
I know we've seen her is it in this
franchise is the question you know I
can't drop everything when we need a
favor life goes
on I can pay you she reminds me of the
girl from Hellboy but I don't think it's
her we can keep this professional is
that what this relationship is now I
told you I needed some time yeah and I I
gave it to you uhoh you don't get to
ghost me for months and then show up out
of nowhere treating me like tech support
this going to drive me nuts she is super
familiar is she the one from Reacher I
was going to say she reminds me of
Reacher's buddy yeah I'm not 100% sure
though are you a collector no the audio
file nerd swear it's the only way to
listen to vinyl they drop two 300,000
Yen on some antique I pulled from
grandpa's garage bunch of pretentious
it's about the crackles and
Pops man I mostly do uh freelance cating
and game design is this from one of your
games your brother did that half brother
and that's still love for debate said
you were an engineer no you said that
wow you're racist
[Music]
lady encryption technology has come a
long way military married 40 years ago
he off the shelf now she the one in
Madam
web
maybe we'll look it up
later uhoh uhoh yeah who else's computer
is
this not I know were thinking hey it's
Collins and data culling I've got
something here you should
see Sophia Lis yes hey yeah great minds
ultimate plot twist her father's
K she just white
ping someone tried to run it through
some online decryption software it's got
a monarch recognition code embedded so
it ping back to us just pulled that up
with the space bar I love these sets
because like the office spaces are so
clutter filled with history messy minds
of
secrecy like it's not Fest thing from
organized yeah it's not all Sleek you
know I'll uh I'll take care of it are
you sure cuz after g day Verdo said she
wanted to see so much for everything you
leave Richard dfus alone let me get back
to my
porno
hey how's your
Japanese
oh who's that who's that who's that
maybe he's calling Kurt Russell he's
called Kurt Russell he's like my
Japanese is good
it looks like that big satellite map in
his
office they were there in San Francisco
like soldiers or something with this on
their uniforms it's a good logo I felt
like the whole city was coming down
people were trapped dying and these guys
were taking pictures they'd been waiting
for it you think that your father was
working for them interesting angle to
take the perspective here after we the
audience have spent three movies
you know it's a very interesting way to
deal with it like to have this like
mysterious ominous Aura to
it oh he wasn't with either of
them nice was the plus five mean five
days after uh no just like this is five
times cooler on the cool scale than gday
what it's like plus five cool points
it's 5 days
later where exactly why are you standing
right now I'm at the Red Cross tent near
the north
entrance dad you have par who just
hang up on you
yeah sorry I just came from
Japan I
[Laughter]
[Music]
rushed
uhoh why would he leave them he's got
important Godzilla work to
do I love you
both why just leaves cheapers man about
a week after that we got a call from the
state police in for ANS Alaska saying
the bush plan he was on disappeared in a
storm they never found the wreckage he's
right Bill dude he's out there he's all
crazy in the woods somewhere he had some
reason for for doing what he did the
answers have to be here and these super
old tapes yes that's why he had two
families yeah well you know he had two
families because of the growth of the
franchise the roots in Japan but the
augmentation from the American side to
understand
both that's my grandmother
hey she died when he was little why is
her picture in these files what is she
standing in so Monarch is a family
business huh yeah
oh I was like yeah I was like what
so this I
know are we're going to see that photo
yeah we're going to see her photo came
to be the the the last shot of the
episode will be her in the footprint
same as you Billy just
closer so grumpy thank you to use a
bigger word cantankerous he is a
cantankerous guy it's a good vocab
word a bit of a keragen you might say
you lost me English
please shoot power the reactor must have
drawn them towards a surface to
feed
yes hey forget the timeline we got to go
one more minute no we got to go
now I love scientists in these
movies how was a roar
thanks oh my God yes oh my God go you
did
this come on oh come on Anders home or
whatever your name
is oh my
God going be freaking
heavy wow it's like World War
Z it's like what actual
oh roaches are rats
[Music]
too that that's icky this is reminded me
of Peter Jackson Kong a little bit
Yeah his voice got so screechy yeah
God Indiana let it
go take a
[Laughter]
photo a damn
yeah I mean we got to see how that photo
came to be how'd she have a kid I know
she they establish I forget at the
beginning of the story they say they had
a
kid you know what I mean remember
they're talking about the kid thing yes
in the car her and Anders or whatever uh
yes they they have a kid on the way they
have a kid on the way yeah yeah yeah
yeah cuz that's going to be the dad yeah
yeah so they have so this is fine I
think I think the kid's on the way right
there's a kid somewhere that it's going
to be her dad oh my God so there's like
M blood in them that runs through their
veins got to be something like that I
think Now's the Time to hyper theorize
yes and be massively disappointed by
what the outcome is yeah yeah if she
doesn't have some well I mean you know
the lore clearly sets up for the ability
to telepathically commune with creatures
and maybe this is where that's coming
from yeah there some Hollow Earth Juju
right
there I'm excited I like it I love how
this episode was like just get Kong and
Godzilla out of the way
for everyone is wondering are they going
to make a cameo just get it out of the
way we let you speculate on anyone else
but these two it's coming right out of
that
yeah let's rewind that dialogue back
really quick cool before we uh yeah I
want to make sure I want to make sure
okay right here they go to Kazakhstan
they're talking about Borat and she's
going to have the son who's going to be
the Borat the origin is oh yeah
okay he's complaining comedy there's
comedy happening right now a good review
yeah I I just don't want to cut drinking
in the
environment got a Kansas City hat old
timey hat
hey there time I com in back seat you
guys back seat commentary we are just
making up to fill the time
here I could just jump cut past this but
we're not doing that this is the real
we're going to discover this in
real time oh man so many so much radi we
clearly re back too far too far
hopefully they cut away from this into
the future I never plan on having kids
anyway uhoh
never that's right cuz we thought they
were flirting with each other
history but he lost out to ERS
right oh he met the right woman but it's
your
woman make it look easy uhhuh raised a
great raised a great kid kids already
born yeah raised in a great kids already
that sense yeah and thus anything we
else have to say about this episode
until we found out because was we could
have gotten very out of hand here and
rewatching that scene they CLE clearly
had sexual attention they did W Russell
and the mom oh yeah do you think that's
really his kid you think we're going to
discover you think we're really going to
discover okay so she got white blood in
her she got white man's blood
yes she do they're going to discover
yeah that that that I mean they already
do because he's if he's the
dad well either way I mean our our two
characters in the present have a shared
white granddaddy exactly yeah when it's
but I think we're going to find out
Wyatt Russell cuz it seems like this
show for some reason is dealing so much
with Legacy
lineage family family family dramas and
a monarch is really like a evil family
it's like the Godfather of the Gods of
the world yeah it's a family business
Hier you're going to have to take over
hierarch and that's why why Russell is
acting the way that he's acting he's so
uh uh cantankerous because he's
begrudgingly you know kind of keeping
this business alive when really he just
wants to go off and do other things
right right and but I I think I'm right
about that that they have sexual tension
Beyond I feel it's probably really his
kid huh I I could absolutely see that
yeah I mean he looks after her like it's
yeah and the way they they especially
trade that line about like there was a
time when you wanted yeah there was a
time or whatever that whatever he says
back like that's directly about having a
kid so you know it seems like like
interpersonal family drama is such a
thing about this I mean it kind of
started off that way with the 2014 one
in a way yeah about like Dad Dad you
weren dead you're so absorbed in your
Godzilla work you weren't there for us
it was awkward growing up in Japan as a
child it's a white
kid which I appreciate it yeah um but as
terms of the first episode I thought it
was a really solid start I thought it
was really solid like something like
this can easily get bogged down and
Easter eggs which I'm sure there's
probably some that we missed Easter eggs
and World building and oh my God they
reference the thing I know which is
another form of Easter eggs and this
just decided to keep it more in its mood
and its overall Aura and its characters
and I think every actor here is pretty
great not the biggest fan so far of the
perform you know always give things time
let a season play out um and see how the
choices are really feeling uh the Sun
the I feel like they the WR that's the
only part of it where the writing and
the per it's kind of going hand in hand
with writing and performance yeah it's
like it's it just the writing or is it
the performance is it both you know is
the actor just doing what he that's the
only part of it where I'm like not the
biggest fan of the way the execution of
him is going down the plot mechanic sure
totally you can accept that but this is
very just one note I'm back and forth
right now on the way they're just
orchestrating the whole half brother
sister lost dual family thing creates a
pulse to it though John oh sure I mean
like I like everything they're doing on
paper and I mean it's funny like sitting
watching this and thinking to myself
like oh you know some of the some some
of the dialogue or some of the you know
character beats could feel a little less
scripted in a comic book somewhere it's
about on par with the last two movies
but go then I go off and think well it's
about on par with the movies and also
everyone loves to immediately kick in
the door and be like no one cares about
humans in a Godzilla but at the same
time we're doing a show and that's what
I'm saying why I like to start because
the whole point is are getting you to
care about the humans yeah and I and I I
like everybody enough that I'm you know
in I want to see where this goes and I
hope it pulls me in further it's like I
like everything that they're doing in
terms of like building the world and the
Intrigue and all that stuff like that's
all very enticing and neat and for boing
and Atmospheric and I like the cast
enough and I like what they're going for
with the drama enough and now just as
for my taste I'm hoping like oh maybe I
hope later on some of this human drama
feels a little more human rather than
like good story intent you know like
good choices but also I you know I just
want to feel the scene's breathe whereas
it feels very much like stick to this
sort of more comic book esque dialogue
for these bits yeah yeah I'm not super
connected to anyone yet um even the main
character who is the daughter yeah uh
like she's good like every everyone like
I said everyone's good um but by this
point I would still feel like well it's
we were here for like almost an hour I
would like to feel like I really love
one of these guys I want to really be
bonded to some who's the one guy one
person I'm really drawn to right now
yeah and right now because even for like
Godzilla I I remember even the 2014
Godzilla movie I mean sure maybe because
it's Brian cron Brian cranon but I
remember of him being like so bumy died
so early because he was so great yeah
wow he's acting his ass off and they are
kind of giving our m
girl um like both the Aaron Taylor
Johnson and Brian Cranston role in a way
you know what I mean of like the the do
the child of the scientist who knew more
and is now solving the rest of the
mystery while also getting into the
adventure themselves and was also on
ground for a lot of this stuff yeah it's
like very much in the in the demean of
the Aaron Taylor Johnson character but
you have a feeling she's going to be
called to be some kind of Greater more
you know involved presence because of
her lineage and and the fact that she's
a something of a chosen one in this
story and I am curious as to what CU
like right now it is really building on
like a a mystery tone and and it is more
just what mystery are they going to
unpack like I I like the
tone and but the puzzle box that they
are lay laying here for us to
investigate yeah like
what what is it that we don't know
already what is it going to be that
isn't just like oh that we unleashed a
new Kaiju like we've gotten we've gotten
pretty far into the godsilla world with
like Hollow Earth and really getting to
know Monarch and all these things that
we are at a point now where I'm like we
have discovered quite a lot so I'm not
saying there's not something more to
discover it it is just right now with
the the questions they have posed or the
thing they're like hey this door were
about to let you walk through um what
what is it going to be other than I the
the family was involved with Monarch
well yeah it's and who's Ken Watson
obi's children when it's Ken watsi going
to show up and take credit for all the
Japanese people I want him to I was
hoping he'd be the dad so he could see
the kids and he could be like Let Them
Fight Let Them Fight for which of my
families was legit
it yeah that would be the best bit of
fan service
imaginable but I don't want to make it's
not complain it just it it it is just
there there has been a lot of hype
around this show as like hey this is
great and yeah I mean like visually it
just it looks like Cinema you know it's
very cinematically appealing from sound
design uh visual effects and the visual
effects are more than just big like they
they're on the quality of any of the
movies yeah for the most part yeah there
was some early moments where I was like
I could catch like a green screen or
whatever but I just really liked I
really have legs in frame today they are
like super like my legs are really here
yes yeah man sometimes they're just but
they they're really I'm really legged
and thank God I lotion my knees anyway
um cuz they're usually quite ashy sure
please talk while I look up who that
girl was
100% uh yeah I mean I feel like there's
where we are in the timeline makes me
curious because we've seen enough of the
past and enough of this present in 2014
and surrounding that I it makes you
wonder what we could learn that Monarch
wouldn't already know but we haven't
seen so much of their mysterious you
know backlog of information uh and who
knows where we might go toward the
future with this it's like yeah if
you're looking ahead towards Godzilla
versus Kong we've already been to Hollow
Earth but I don't know yeah I I don't
know really what kind of reveal I would
want and I think a big part of the
satisfaction kiry Clemens she's Iris
West that's who that is oh my got
Justice League yeah and the Flash and
all that yeah flash definitely well and
you know she got put back dis Justice
League um yeah like right now I think
it's enough that like it doesn't have to
be anything like crazy mindblowing
although I do like a good like
conspiracy crypto zoology kind of things
so I feel like you can play with a a lot
there and I think that yeah like the
tone and the lived in quality of how
they're portraying this post uh you know
Titan world is pretty fun and engaging
yeah uh and and yeah like you know the
use and I like how
Godzilla um even though Godzilla is not
I imagine not going to be in the show a
lot like yeah the after effect like
that's one of the things I find the most
compelling about it is the civilian
after effect and the trauma and just the
way the world has really Chang like
we've seen in the movies where people
are like fascinated by by it and Titans
but we're really like like the little
attention to details like when they get
on the plane and and it's like hey it
might be linked to you know like human
viruses carrying yeah we got spray
you down spray down all the like warning
signs like how it's treated like it's a
virus in a way you know I think like
there's something on us that they're
attracted to or whatever it is and like
seeing like the nuclear weapons or not
nuclear weapons but like the the
missiles and stuff ready launch at a
moment's notice like we just got to
prepare like there's just a fear of
goetta you know permeating everywhere
toally and I really love that stuff a
lot yeah know lots of love it's well
lived in and it and it complement the
films that have come before it in fun
and interesting ways and I'm I'm excited
actually in like a nod Pander sort of
Easter egg kind of way just like the way
it cuz I like I think the PTSD thing is
a really solid device in this context
because it enhances the monster movie
quality that these things have and the
trauma that Godzilla and the surrounding
circumstance that begets Godzilla
represents definely um so that's like a
neat device for something like this to
kind of freshen it up and allow allow
you to kind of have Godzilla action
wherever you want but also in a way that
that makes some sense and then you know
when there's like present very
intentional Kaiju stuff I'm sure that's
going to be cool like the whole big
daddy longleg spider bit with Rand the
beginning was was super fun like there
were there were a couple moments where
I'm Dan Conor yes of
course this is the real end of the
coners right here uh but yeah like it
was enough of like connective tissue to
be satisfying that way but also you know
allowing this to be its own thing enough
so it's like there's good enough room to
improve on the drama that hopefully
that'll clinch by the end it's like I
feel like the one thing I felt during
this was like this could use maybe just
like a tiny ounce of that Overlord
energy where it's like this is still
taking it seriously but uh I don't know
like especially with the three
scientists like I want a little bit more
flavor on that like I'm excited to see
that grow especially now that she's like
falling into the pit like I think
there's going to be some fun stuff ahead
for that me too man uh overall yeah I
thought it was a really solid start I'm
definitely I'm definitely intrigued by
what's happening and um can't help but
admit like you know it just the the idea
of the preconceived notion a Godzilla's
Monarch you know that whenever like the
monster Stuff shows up there is that
part of me it's like oh finally yeah
yeah every time it is like like I'm
enjoying what I'm watching but it is
like oh yes thank you well it's a more
agreeable circumstance to be like okay
I'm not going to expect to see only
Godzilla specifically and Kaiju
generally all the time but when it
happens yeah I'll be psyched cuz yeah
you can't mess with the timeline too
because like in the timeline of this
Godzilla have a bunch of
extra Godzilla shows up and then
Godzilla's like the time she's shown up
are in the three movies so you can't
mess with that timeline yeah 14 onward
yeah um but you know we can do tons of
random wacky on that island in the
7 on Skull Island in the 70s if we want
to um but but but I'd like the
recontextualization for what our main
character is feeling because by this
point in the story you know it's like of
Godzilla it's like he's he's he's kind
of like an anti-hero in our world yeah
you know and then this brings it
to that it's like an anti-hero or
something just or or like civilians are
kind of just caught in the middle of
something that bigger that's happening
you're either the benefactor of
Godzilla's protection or you're standing
directly in the way yeah yeah but he's
not like going to protect you and and or
she yeah they well the rolling Emer one
it was I don't know what the the the the
specifics of lizards are like if you
need to be a lady lizard I feel like
they specified it in one of the movies
which one
I mean unless we're getting real
Progressive I think King implies that
Godzilla is a Godzilla John please
sure is the monster verse
Godzilla male female or other is the
monster
verse
Godzilla female or male let's find out
yes find out tune in next week we'll
give you an
answer uh never explicitly stated in the
film
the Japanese ones yes use M yes yes yes
yes um and then the 1998 one uh was
pushing woke agendas yes yes of course
yes of interpreted Godzilla be gender
1998 American Godzilla film and
characters referred to as a she by
scientist yeah John really knows that
one I
do I loved that movie as a
kid I've watched it since then but but
yeah um o o overall the I don't remember
what we're talking about yeah let's uh
we're
what did you guys think about it leave
your thoughts down below uh be sure to
subscribe leave a like and hey let's
send this with a shout out yes what's
going on guys so uh you know we're only
so many days left in the month here so
we got to shout out two patrons for two
of our Patron the day of shout outs
going to do it in one but it's going to
be
qualitative I'm I'm going to choose
today right now John to shout out David
Yandy and uh Tyler hay oo what a lovely
soothing combination I mean they're both
white men and I both white feel like you
know wher the B stick together white
guys stick together so first things
first on the agenda David Gandy the
camera we are shooting off of right now
you have gifted us with this and it has
been a treasure chest of Discovery even
the other day I was like John do we have
a wide lens what do knew for 4K many
lens and John spent about an hour and a
half just experimenting with all the
lenses and then we ultimately resort to
let go back to what we were using
before this is definitely the one that's
most compatible for through all those
lenses we learned even more about other
lenses we did we did someday these will
be in 4k all thanks to you but David you
have uh opened our eyes up to many a
things and Beyond gifting us with stuff
you have also expanded our Horizon so
thank you so much much for being you and
I hope you're having a wonderful
Thanksgiving in Arizona easily the most
festive state in the world absolutely uh
Tyler hey my guy uh I don't I think it
sounds like it might be beating a dead
horse here over me talking about how
years ago you gifted me with a PS4 but
I'm pretty sure my gaming days might
have been done if it wasn't for you if
you had not gifted me that at a time
where Financial need was bad uh and and
then having that allowed me to continue
on with uh easily one of my favorite
Escapist hobbies that I find kind of
meditative rather meditative honestly uh
I don't think I would still game if it
weren't for you so thank you for
allowing me to still have that uh what I
find to be a necessary form of escapism
and for always being quite jovial with
us regardless man uh even if we dip in
and out of being being able to have our
long conversations and and just and I
know I can be laid on messages but I
really appreciate you dude so thank you
thank you sure John had a weirder thing
in mind always something about David
adopting Tyler yeah yeah and then David
would like connect his camera cuz he's a
photographer right to all of Tyler's
screens and then Tyler can like direct
while David is DP and then you guys
start like a film career where you make
these films out of all these action
figur
and that Tyler can use his video game
love to then add graphics and stuff like
that maybe he learns how to do CGI so
then all these little action figure
films can be like the fan films that we
so often you know desire but never
receive because of the constraints of
working with human actors you
know these two could start a revolution
all right in stop motion filmmaking
that's all I'm saying okay you guys are
great and creative and I love you
both and I'm very soothed just thinking
about the both see the thing is I think
we would get them together and they
would just like emit this sort of
calming om you know two chillest guys at
the patreon and I feel like that's good
we could all use a little bit more of
that yes we
could thank you both very much stay sexy
thanks for being here and we'll catch
you next
[Music]
month